if you're watching this I know you
clicked on this video that's right I
also know you're watching this right now
I also know you're feeling extremely
extremely attracted right now to what
you're looking at
don't worry this is all normal where am
I going with this
nowhere clickbait yes my main or a woman
click page today's video is all about
clickbait one of my favorite things in
the world after making good videos but
this time the roles have reversed you
bros aren't supposed to click bait mate
the click bait master I asked you bros
last week to click baby let's see how
you did I will judge your click bait
from a scale to 1 to give them a lot of
numbers in between them ok so I will
pick the best click bait ask the click
bait for this video
who's going to win it all so for next
week I want you guys to just draw fanart
any sort of fan art no level of skill
required ok I just just want banner
doesn't have to be of me please be on me
why am i quitting YouTube the truth I
need to tell you something not quickly
the suspects - did you know it's real
when your eyes are lately just [ __ ] so
over overly edited that they just write
that truth about me quitting YouTube 10
top 10 pictures that prove Hitler is
still alive not quickly you know it's
not clickbait when it says not clickbait
very well played I'll give that one a
0.4 it's not related to science click
here to find out nothing okay maybe this
one isn't click play then unlucky you
cut off my [ __ ] head good job Beauty
Paul joins team 10 billions and millions
of dollars money money money and NASA's
him in Paul's trick what you know its
clickbait because I'm not in team thing
my girlfriend tried to poison me not
quickly well I mean she doesn't make a
lot of dessert
moving on top 5 youtubers killed on
camera
[Music]
it's correct
Oh me and Jack are getting married that
seemed plausible that seems entirely
possible and he said he also took my
beer Congrats yeah who knows you know
that that's the key of clickbait who
knows this is probably clickbait but i'm
going to click to find out anyway
there's boobs into thumbnail and they're
probably not going to be in the video
but a is like cancer [ __ ] so I'm going
to click anyway what else am I going to
do with my life literally anything else
I think I will find out if there are
kids in this video thank you very much
the floristry well that's just a meme ok
[ __ ] off ok Petey pyres nude bleep
you know with that amount of emojis it
has to be correct in any legitimate
evidence file if you don't have at least
20 emojis it's factually incorrect okay
dab on them hater bugs are bad
[Music]
god I don't think this is for PvP but
look at that hot dog hot dog hot dog is
how high what the hell man he's just
trying to hide his eyes for me probably
the best campaign for drugs I have ever
seen oh hi mark
your boy Franco gave me a part in the
room oh that would be amazing but they
already filmed it [ __ ] you Franco my
girlfriend cheated on me with hot
British rapper no Nick Crump did you son
of a [ __ ] he's the only one I would let
cook me okay I would be happy to port
for Nick but that seemed like I was
serious and now I regret that joke okay
P deep I caught disrespecting women via
my god have you bought one of the shirts
yet by the way at Lincoln bio merch
Lincoln bio PT PI and jacksepticeye have
fun [ __ ] off
haha get me good me yeah you know I'm
top level you know these these people
they can't compare people don't
understand that I've been doing this for
years okay
it's not some trend that I just jump on
around like okay all the sudden I
respect women now just get the tip and
cool now I've been together since the
beginning and you guys know it you
followed me my hardcore bros sisters of
course have known it for years it's in
the beer okay I am NOT I'm not just
respecting women I am growing respect
for women this is a visual
representation
what's your visual reciprocation for
respecting women that's right you don't
having your ugly face uh-huh I don't
think so thank you [ __ ] there it is
again
I love how to you just flew by both of
us completely that that might look weird
two men undressing and then bending over
in front of each other multiplier react
to top 10 sexy of all time I don't know
why this is funny I think it is the fact
that you would cry if anyone looks at
you like this get fired from Disney
Channel welcome to the family no no no
he wasn't fired it was a mutual
agreement you know just like people
break out at the same time it is really
is this crazy coincidence that both
people just come from this point eight
two point B they meet and then they like
hey we should break up at the exact same
time it's incredible
what are they are yet it happens all the
time my girlfriend is Fergana nanana
seems legit I might go with this one for
this video actually
oh yes recreated PewDiePie's Nick come
Nick Crompton portrait in pastels that's
[ __ ] awesome I love it that's so funny
I did this video where I literally just
drew memes there it is that's my version
I would buy I always buy the [ __ ] that's
a beautiful art that's a beautiful piece
of art that's the next Mona Lisa eating
my dog's ass for views this is good
click face because you know it's
possible that I would actually think
that low so that's how you know it it
it's something outlandish and insane but
it's still possible but that's how you
commit to a great click place well this
is just a picture but it's amazing but I
guess I got click baited into clicking
into your fine art so I guess account I
don't know okay yes that's what I want
on my gravestone zero death I'm still
here I'm still I'm still alive I swear
they buried me alive I'm still alive
someone help me please zero depth all
right now we're on the last page so this
click page has to be good right the only
points I'm going to give here is that
everything emoji in the arrow but that's
about it
it's pretty [ __ ] I'm not gonna lie mark
my trash yeah got naked for PewDiePie in
front of camera you won't believe what
could if I said no ass [ __ ] the best the
best the best where man disrespect ur
Tatum's learn how the Swedish man became
a millionaire using this simple trick
that's a pretty good day I click wait
it's this [ __ ] made but it's good click
thing thumbnails actually look hot yeah
yes so good why am i why I'm joining
team ten that's pretty good this could
be potential material finally after
three hundred years I found content
I don't understand what you guys have to
be so mean to me all the time okay
I made four thousand videos okay I'm
sure at least one of them is can qualify
haha that is sexual equality me I like
it that's good [ __ ] man
okay evolution of PewDiePie content NOx
a klay Thompson god damn it it's so
accurate - here is where I keep my will
- limb from his last vlog okay moving on
see how this guy lost weight no
clickbait under present real effective
no Mick Ronson doesn't need to lose
anyway he was perfect okay he's a
beautiful specimen and he doesn't need
to change everything about I think I'm
going to go with why I'm joining team
ten it's a strong title and it's an
interesting thumbnail okay and it's
relevant you know it's going to get
those views but thank you again bros for
doing my work for me
you've all been tricked ah oh he doesn't
have anything original yes because I
don't have to do anything original you
dumb son - [ __ ] I got foxy
let's see if I just got shoot what mixed
move [ __ ] okay next time don't forget
to do the fan art really appreciate it
for real though bro sister